مجلس الامن يدعو طالبان لتراجعي عن
السياسات التي تستهدف النساء
يقول ان استبعاد المراه انتكاسه كبيره
ايطاليا تحتاج على ممارسات نظام طهران
وتستدعي السفير الايراني بروما و100
متظاهر يواجهون خطرا الاعدام
رئيس وزراء اوكرانيا يقول ان نصف منشات
الطاقه عطلت بسبب القصف وسلطات تتهم كيف
باستهدافي اجزاء في المنطقه
[موسيقى]
طبتم وطابت اوقاتكم اهلا بكم الى نشرتنا
اخباريه من العربيه
اعرب الامين العام الامم المتحده انطوني
من قرار حركه طالبان منع النساء من العمل
في المنظمات غير الحكوميه الوطنيه
التي فرضتها حركه الطالبان على تعليم وعمل
المراه هي انتهاكات غير مبرره لحقوق
الانسان
في الملف الافغانيه ايضا واوضاع النساء في
ظل حكومه طالبان فقد حذر مجلس الامن
الدولي من ان منع عمل النساء في منظمات
الاغاثه يحملوا تداعيات تداعيات على
عمليات الاغاثه في افغانستان ويخالف
التزامات طالبان تجاه حقوق الشعب الافغاني
امام المجتمع الدولي واعرب مجلس الامن عن
قلقه شديد من قرار طالبان منع الافغانيات
من التعليم الجامعي كما دعى مجلس الامن
الدولي الى مشاركه كامله وفاعله للنساء
والفتيات في افغانستان
طيب يا صديقي مذيعه في محطه التيفي واحد
تتحسر على مغادره عدد كبير من زميلاتها
البلد بعد تحولات الاخيره في البلد تقول
ان القيام بالمهام الاعلاميه اصبح صعبا
بالنسبه للمراه الافغانيه
من السيدات وقد قل عددهن بشكل كبير والان
لدينا عدد محدود وقليل جدا
تعمل كم مراسله الميدانيه للمحطه تقول انك
راسي زميلاتها شاغره بجنبها وذلك لانهن
تركن العمل وذهبنا خارج البلد
والبعض الاخر استقنا منها الاعلاميه
المجال الاعلامي من المجالات التي لا
تقرها طالب لعمل مراه بينما سيده
الافغانيه تراه مناسبا لعملها وذلك لان
العمل فيه سهل مقارنه بالمجالات الاخرى
يرى العديد من الافغان انه اذا استمر
استبعاد المراه من العمل فانه سيتضرر
ملايين الاسر والاطفال وسيتعين على الشعب
الى الافغاني التعامل مع ازمه اقتصاديه
خطيره عبد المنذر العربيه كابول
[موسيقى]
استدعى وزير الخارجيه الايطاليه انطونيو
تاجاني السفيره الايراني في روما للاحتجاج
على ما وصفه بالقمع غير المقبول لتظاهرات
التي تقودها النساء في ايران وافقي ما
اعلنكتبه وسبق عندنا الوضع في ايران ووصفه
بانه عار غير مقبول قائلا ان روما تتبنى
نهجا صارما في الدفاع عن المراه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اعلنت منظمته حقوق الانسان الايرانيه
ارتفاع عدد قتلى المظاهرات المستمره في
البلاد منذ اكثر من ثلاثه اشهر الى 400
و76 قتيلا وذكرت المنظمه انا من بين ضحايا
المظاهرات
64لا و 34 امراه واشارت الى ان ما لا يقل
عن 100 متظاهري يواجهون حاليا خطر الاعدام
او اتهامات تفضي الى هذه العقوبه
نقش يا رئيس الاوكرانيه فلوديميرازيلنسكي
مع رئيسه الوزراء الايطاليه جورجيا ميلوني
ما سالتها تزويد بلاده بانظمه دفاع جوي
يشير الى ان يشار الى ان ميلونيت ستزور
كيف مطلع العمل المقبل
سيسمح لنا بتقويه الدفاعاتنا وحمايه
سمائنا
حضر رئيس وزراء اوكرانيا دينيس شميغل من
ان الحرب الروسيه احدثت ضررا واسعا في
البنيه التحتيه في اوكرانيا منذ فبراير
الماضي وفي تفاصيل حصيله الاضرار قرا
المسؤول الاوكراني ان نحو 35 الف منشات
تعطلت منذ بدايه الحرب من بينها 700 من
مرافق طاقه الحيويه لا سيما انابيب نقل
الغاز ومولدات الكهرباء والجسور اي ما
يساوي نصف محطه الطاقه في البلاد ما يعني
ان اجراءات صارمه ستتخذ في استهلاك الطاقه
حتى حلو للربيع
افادت سلطات المواليه لروسيا في دونيسك
بتعرض منطقه بتروفسكي وكيروفسكي لقصف عنيف
بالمدفعيه الثقيله من الجانب الاوكراني
واضاف المسؤولون ان القوات الاوكرانيه
استهدفت ايضا بمجموعه من الصواريخ
ياسنافتايا التي تضم اكبر محطه سكه حديد
في المنطقه
برجو مراقبه طوره لواء الدفاع الاقليميه
تابع للقوات الاوكرانيا بهدف مراقبه
تحركات القوات الروسيه البرج اعتمد على
مبدا مشابه اليه اجهزه المراقبه الامريكيه
ويحمل كاميرا بمدى خمسه كيلومترات
[موسيقى]
كاميرا الفيديو
توقعاتنا بنحسار العاصفه الثلجيه في
امريكا
اهلا بكم من جديد بدات مدينه بوفالو
الامريكيه التي غطتها الثلوج وشلت الحركه
فيها شله الحركه فيها بلملمه جراحها بعد
ان الثامنه عاصفه ثلجيه فيما بدا
المواطنون بازاله الثلوج واصلاح المناطق
المنتظره
[موسيقى]
هكذا تحولت حياه الامريكيين بعد عاصفه
القرن التي تسببت بكوارث على نطاق اثنتي
عشره ولايه امريكيه مع انهيار خدمات
الطوارئ في عدد من المناطق بشكل ماساوي
تجمد كل شيء المياه والطرقات شهود عيان
يفيدون بوجود الجثث متجمده داخل السيارات
المغموره
وفقه حاكمه ولايه
نيويوركان عمليات الاغاثه والاخضر عجز
طواقم الدفاع المدني عن الوصول الى ناجين
عالقين اما في مناز او على الطرقات
[موسيقى]
وفي المقابل توقف شبه تام في قطاع الخدمات
وشركات الطيران تلغي رحلتها بسبب سوء
احوال الطقس حيث الغت ساوث
2474 رحله وفقا لموقع فلايت وير لتتبع
حركه الطائرات
الارصاد الجويه الامريكيه اصدرت تقريرا
محدثا يتضمن توقعات بانحصار العاصفه
القطبيه وخصوصا في شرق ووسط الولايات
المتحده
وتبدو المناطق التي ضربتها العاصفه اشبه
بساحه حرب سيارات معطله على جانبي الطرقات
بيوت مغموره على ارتفاع مترين بثلوج سكان
نحو تسع ولايات بلا كهرباء او خدمات في
وقت تتعثر فيه جهود الاغاثه بسبب الرياح
وتدني الرؤيا والجليد على الطرق
المشهد الصادم في ولايه نيويورك وتحديدا
بوفالو شوارع خاليه من الماره ومن اي حركه
باستثناء الرياح والثلوج
مباني شبه مهجوره بلا اضاءه بانتظار حصيله
ثقيله على الاغلب مع انحصار العاصفه
القطبيه
[موسيقى]
هكذا رئيس الحكومه الليبيه المكلف من
البرلمان فتحي باشا ان الوقت ليس لصالح
الليبيين داعيا الى ضروره المصالحه
والخروج سريعا من الوضع الراهن في البلاد
واشرب شاغه الى ان كل المناطق في ليبيا
تعاني بسبب مواصفات بغياب الدوله وانقسام
المؤسسات
تعكس اللي ضربات التي تستهدف بشكل اساسي
قطع النقل في بريطانيا خلافات بين حزب
المحافظين والنقابات العماليه
بريطانيا
يخاطر رئيس الوزراء البريطاني الذي لم
يمضي على توليه قياده الحكومه ثلاثه اشهر
بفوضه جديده في البلاد بدايه العام المقبل
مع رفضه مطالبا نقابات برفع الاجور
الاضرابات تتضاعف عددا ورقعه انتشارها
تتسع لتشمل قطاعات عده بعضها يشهد اضرابا
لاول مره كادرابات قطعي الممرضين والاسعاف
في ديسمبر اضافه الى تهديد نقاباتها
بالمزيد من الاضرابات في يناير ما ينظر
بمرحله مقلقه قد يواجهها البريطانيون في
عام 2013
عن تحقيق مطالب النقابات لاسباب يقول انها
اقتصاديه يتجه سوناك الى فرد قوانين تضبط
حركه الاضرابات قوانينه تثير الجدل في بلد
يعطي قيمه كبيره لحريه الاحتجاج
هؤلاء العمال
واذا كان ذلك يعني اضراب العمال فليكن
ولكن اذا جعلت ذلك مخالفه للقانون فانا لا
اعتقد ان هذا امر عادل
ومع اتجاه السوناتا لطرح قوانين للحد من
تحركات العمال هذا لا يبدو ان النقابات
التي تملك زخم الاضرابات تنوي التراجع عن
خطتها قبل تحقيق مطالبها عروب عبد الحق
العربيه
في لبنان هبط سعره صرف الدولار 3000 ليره
بعد قرار حاكم مصر في لبنان رفع سعر الصرف
على منصه صيره
اللبناني يعيش ايامه في ظل الانهيار
الاقتصادي المستمر والدولار الذي حلق
عاليا بسعر صرفه خلال الايام الماضيه فبات
عاجزا عن مقاومه ما يحصل لياتي هبوط سعر
الصرف اليوم عاديه لمواطن تاقلم على كل
شيء غير اعتياديه
معه لبناني طلع الدولار
رياض
38,000 ليره للدولار تقريبا
الى فتره معينه فقط
اللي كلنا متاكدين منه لانه هذا الشيء صار
بنهايه العام 21 اليوم عم يصير بنهايه
العام 22 التي توفي بياني حكيمي مصرف
لبنان تطرقه الى عمليات تهريب الدولار الى
الخارج والتي ساهمت في الازمه تخبط
بالموضوع السياسي في تخبط بالبلد ما في
اصلاحات بنفس الوقت في ضغط على الدولار
الامريكي في مضاربه بشكل مش معقول هي كمان
سبب كبير انه عم يرفع الدولار همم ان احنا
لاحظنا بالارقام انه الاستيراد للبنين صار
تقريبا 17 مليار دولار وهذا يمكن بياكد
الشيء اللي عم يحكي مصري في لبنان انه همم
عم بيكون في ضغط على الدولار لسوريا
والارقام يلي بتقول لي 17 مليار دولار
ليوم استيراد للبنان يعني هذا شيء بياكد
كمان انه نحن اليوم عم نستورد لاقتصادين
مش لاقتصاد واحد يحاولوا لبنان
امتصاص الكتله النقديه الكبيره من العمله
اللبنانيه التي يتم استخدامها في تاجيج
عمليه المضاربه على العمله وشراء الدولار
من السوق السوداء لكن مخاوف الخبراء ان
كانت ايجابيه هذه الخطوه ستكون محدوده
المده انتخاب رئيس للجمهوريه تشكيل حكومه
التدقيق المالي الجنائي والاصلاحات التي
يطلبها صندوق النقد الدولي كفيله ببدر
رحله الخروج من الانهيار الاقتصادي بدلا
من قرار مصر في لبنان الذي يعتبره عدد من
الخبراء حلا مؤقتا وغير مضمون ناهد يوسف
العربيه بيروت
اعلنت فرق الاطفاء في اربيل عن اخماد
الحريق الذي اندلع في مصفاه نفطيه على
طريق اربيل
دون وقوعي اي وفيات رغم الاضرار الماديه
التي احدثها الحريق وذكر قائمه مقام اربيل
ان الغازات المنبعثه من الحريق اسفلت عن
اصابه اثنين من رجال الدفاع المدني احدهما
وضعه صحيحه غير مستقر ويخضع للعلاج في
المستشفى
وهذه وقفه مع ابرز احداث شهر اغسطس هذا
العام
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
يبقى اسود بين مواضيع التعاون
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
دعا كيم جون جون زعيم كوريا الشماليه
لتعزيز الامكانات الدفاعيه لبلاده في
العام 2023 وذلك على خلفيه التصعيد الجاري
في شبه جزيره الكوريه
واوضحت وسائل واعلام عن كوريا الشماليه ان
كيم جونغ اون اعلن خلال انعقاد القمه
الحزبيه عن الاهداف الاساسيه الجديده
لتعزيز الدفاع التي يجب التوصل اليها في
العام 2023 في ظروف الاوضاع المتغيره وكان
الزعيم كم اناقشه سياسات بيونغيانج
ومهماتها الرئيسيه لعام 2023 خلال الجلسه
العامه ثالثه المواسعه لحزب العمال
احتفالا من الذكرى ال 50 لكاسيس كوريا
الشماليه لدستوريها للاشتراكيه يشار الى
ان هذه المره الاولى التي يحضر فيها زعيم
كوريا الشماليه حدثا لاحياء ذكرى اعتماد
البلاد للدستور منذ توليه السلطه في العام
عثرت الشرطه البرازيليه على حقيبه ظهر
بالقرب من مكان اقامه الرئيس المنتخب لويس
سيلفا مما اثر مخوف من وجود قنبله الا ان
الحقيبه كانت تحتوي على متعلقات شخصيه فقط
وقال وزير العدل الجديد ان التوترات
السياسيه في العاصمه دفعت فريق الاولى الى
تعزيز البروتوكولات الامنيه للتنصيب الذي
يجرى يوم الاحد واضاف ان الفريق لانتقالي
سيطلب من المحكمه العليا تعليق حمل
الاسلحه الناريه في برازيليا خلال الايام
القليله المقبله
هكذا البيت الابيض انه سيلتزم بقرار
المحكمه العليا الامريكيه التي قضت
بالالقاء على سياسه الحكومه المستمره منذ
عامين بشان احتياطات صحيه متعلقه بكرونا
لمنعي مئات الالاف من المهاجرين من دخول
البلاد وخاصه عند الحدود مع المكسيك وقالت
المتحدثه باسم البيت الابيض كريم جون كير
في بيان انه هو في الوقت النفسي تتقدم
الاداره الامريكيه في استعدادتها لاداره
الحدود بطريقه امنه ومنظمه وانسانيه عندما
يرفع القرار المتعلق بالهجره رقم 42 مشيره
الى مواصله توسيع المسارات القانونيه
للهجره
العناوين
مجلس الامن يدعو طالبا للتراجع عن
السياسات التي تستهدف النساء يقول ان
استبعاد المراه انتكاسه كبيره
ايطاليا تحتج على ممارسات نظام طهران
وتستدعي السفير الايراني في روما و 100
متظاهر يواجهون خطر الاعدام
رئيس وزراء اوكرانيا يقول ان نسبه منشات
الطاقه تعطلت بسبب القصف والسلطات تتهم
كيف باستهداف اجزائها
في امان الله
[موسيقى]